shots ring out in Oklahoma when officers
discover an armed fugitive hiding under
a mattress in the back of a trailer
shots fired shots fired it happened at
about 10 25 a.m on November 15th in
Oklahoma City Oklahoma officers were
told a Suspect with an out-of-state
warrant was seen entering a trailer the
man identified as Timothy Johnson was
not seen leaving responding officers
spoke with Jennifer Garner the woman who
lives in the trailer she gave police
permission to search inside
it's her Trailer Sammy
this is the police department
if you're in here you need to make
yourself known
body camera video shows multiple
officers searching the trailer for
Johnson
Sammy
hey when officers lift a mattress in the
back of the trailer they find Johnson
armed with a pistol hiding in a storage
area
after that shots rang out
shots fired shots fired body camera
video shows officers returning to the
trailer in an attempt to take Johnson
into custody and secure the area come
out with your hands up come out with
your hands up come out with your hands
up seconds after officers go back inside
the trailer shots ring out again that's
when one of the officers inside is hit
with debris I'm hit I'm hit
we're stuck inside the trailer I'm
hitting in the face
body camera video then shows officers
attempt to make contact with Johnson
again before leaving the trailer to find
a safe area
Timothy
can you come out your hands up
back on the trailer
the Oklahoma City Police Department's
Tactical Team later arrived and found
Johnson dead on the scene investigators
later discovered Jennifer Garner gave
police consent to search her trailer
knowing Johnson was armed and hiding
inside she was arrested and now faces
charges of harboring a fugitive the
officer who was injured was treated at a
nearby hospital and later released now
all three officers involved in the
shooting are on leave pending the
outcome of an investigation for the
latest developments in this story and
all things True Crime stay with long
crime Network I'm Sierra Gillespie